i did i split in those dms
i slid in my dms and you said
yes uh i'd like you on the show we
should kick it sometime and then
then you said below it you said and by
kick it i mean like go on a date nothing
like some good old-fashioned flirting to
start a beautiful friendship earlier
this week demi lovato had shit's creek
star emily hampshire on their 4d with
demi lovato podcast
the two discussed important topics such
as eating disorders queer and identity
issues and navigating the often
difficult entertainment industry i guess
i never thought of myself as anorexic
but i was
really
you know
white knuckling it through that counting
everything and then i couldn't do it
anymore however things got a little
steamy when emily asked the dancing with
the devil singer if they remembered
their first interaction demi jokingly
poked fun at the situation saying a
non-binary person can dream you know
what i mean the pair continued to
reminisce on the hilarious interaction
by noting their age difference with demi
comparing them to a well-known hollywood
queer couple
you also said think about sarah falson
and holland taylor
no
then right after you're like
i don't mean you're the holland taylor i
was like
[Music]
[Music]
although the pair are now great friends
they also stated that they are both
happily single and probably singing
along to i love
me is enough
[Applause]
[Music]